In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, amen.
The reading from the Sinaxadion for July 16 on which we commemorate the Holy Haramarder
Athena Yenis.
On the 16th of the month, we celebrate the memory of the Holy Haramarder Athena Yenis, Bishop
of Bidakto, and of his ten disciples.
While the persecution begun by Diocletian and continued by Galerius, circa the year 305
was raging throughout the Empire, inciting children to betray their parents, and spreading
blood and terror everywhere.
The governor Filamacos arrived in the town of Sebast, in lesser Armenia, preceded by
a procession of pagan priests, with flute and symbol players.
He ceded himself at once in his tribunal, and had a herald proclaim that the whole population
was to present itself to sacrifice to the Emperor's gods.
But the crowd cried out with one voice, we are Christians, and we shall not sacrifice
to idols.
A great massacre immediately took place, offering to God a cohort of valiant martyrs.
A certain Nicholas then informed the governor that Athena Yenis, the Korepiscopos, who lived
in a monastery in Bidakto, was encouraging the people to disobey the Emperor's edicts.
A detachment of soldiers was sent to the monastery, but not finding the saint, they arrested his
ten disciples whom they chained and took to Sebast.
The governor had them thrown into prison and ordered that their leader be found.
When he returned to the monastery the next day, Athena Yenis searched high and low for his
disciples, and not finding them, prayed with tears to God, a doe which had been brought
up at the monastery since its birth, went up to the saint, kissed his feet, and then spoke
in a human voice, revealing that they had been arrested and taken to Sebast to be martyred.
The saint blessed the animal and hurriedly departed for the town.
Entering the tribunal he cried out to the tyrant that he was drawing divine anger upon himself
for all the sufferings inflicted on the Christians.
He was immediately thrown into prison where, to his joy, he found his disciples and was
able to encourage them to persevere to the end, and so take their place at the banquet
to which Christ had invited them.
The next day they appeared before Philomacus, who vowed to hand them over to the most horrible
of tortures, as he had done to the Christians before them, who refused to offer sacrifice.
The Holy Bishop replied that those blessed martyrs were now rejoicing with the angels,
and that he and his disciples had but one desire to join them.
The governor had the saints' disciples stretched on an iron frame and ordered his men to
lacerate their sides.
When they remained unflinching and mocked the tyrant while they were being tortured, he had
them beheaded, and thus they inherited paradise as their reward.
Athens was summoned to see the spectacle from close at hand, and Philomacus said to him,
where is your Christ?
Why does he not come to deliver your companions?
The saint was then in his turn stretched on a frame and beaten on the ribs.
After the blows he cried, Lord, I place my trust in thee, save me in thy mercy.
A voice was then heard from heaven.
Take courage, my chosen one, and fear not for I am with you to deliver you.
As the torturers had become as men paralyzed, Philip, the governor's counselor, cried out,
I told you truly this was a magician, rid us of him quickly.
Philomacus then pronounced the death sentence, but at the saint's request he agreed that
the execution would take place in the monastery.
As the courteige came in sight of the monastery, the doe ran forward and prostrated itself at
the saint's feet.
Atheno Yenis said to it, You have been deprived of your brothers, and soon of the one who brought
you up.
May God grant your progeny never to fall to the hunter.
In condition that, each year, on the anniversary of our death, you offer one of your young as
a sacrifice on the day of our year's mind.
He then blessed the animal and sent it away in peace, addressing a prayer to God for those
who would celebrate his memory, and receiving the response to his prayer from on high, he
bowed his neck to the sword and went to join his disciples in the joy of the heavenly banquet.
The saint's wish was heard.
After his death, when his memory was celebrated each year, a doe would enter the church at
the moment when the gospel was about to be read at the liturgy, carrying one of its young
in its mouth, and would place it at the foot of the altar.
The Christians would then offer the animal to God and eat it joyfully to the glory of God,
in honor of saint Atheno Yenis.
Through the prayers of our Holy Father's O Lord, Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us,
and save us.